en los últimos vídeos evaluamos esta
integral de línea de esta trayectoria
usando el teorema de stocks diciendo
esencialmente que es equivalente a una
integral de superficie del rotacional df
cuando hacemos el producto punto con el
vector normal a la superficie lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es mostrarles
que no tuvimos necesariamente que usar
el teorema de stocks que realmente
pudimos simplemente evaluar la integral
de línea y lo que hay que tener en mente
en este caso es que es realmente como un
volado a veces determinar cuál es la
integral más fácil de hacer pero el
teorema de 'stocks' es valioso porque a
veces es mejor realizar la integral de
superficie que la de línea así que
intentemos evaluar ahora la integral de
línea y esperemos obtener la misma
respuesta si es que hacemos todo
correctamente entonces vamos a vamos a
empezar parametrizado esta curva ok
vamos a necesitar parametrizar la curva
para poder resolver el problema entonces
ya hemos hecho esto muchas ocasiones
vamos a voy a hacerlo nuevamente aunque
sea un poco más rápido
todos los dos ejes está un poco checo
ahí está
voy a pintar los dos ejes digamos aunque
no se vea tan derechito este es el eje y
el eje x y lo que vamos a hacer es
parametrizar por ejemplo primero el
círculo unitario ok entonces podemos
pintar aquí
nuestro círculo unitario perfecto digo
es un poquito chueco pero se entiende la
idea y lo que vamos a hacer es
introducir un parámetro que vamos a
llamar teta porque la letra griega teta
que generalmente usamos justamente para
para ángulos verdad entonces nuestro
ángulo teta vamos a tener que utilizarlo
si vamos a quererle dar sólo una vuelta
al círculo unitario pues lo tendremos
entre 0 ok que es cuando no tengo un
ángulo ok entonces el ángulo está entre
0 y 2 pi como parámetro en la variable x
esto es en el plano xy verdad entonces x
simplemente usando
pues las identidades o las funciones
trigonométricas aquí si el radio es 1
pues x es el coseno del ángulo verdad
simplemente es la base de este triángulo
entonces x es igual al coseno del ángulo
mientras que es la altura que es el seno
del ángulo como vamos a parametrizar z
bueno vamos a obtenerlo de esta
expresión ye maceta es igual a 2 por lo
tanto z es igual a 2 - pero jesse no
detecta por lo tanto 7 es igual a 2
menos
el seno de t está aquí lo que estamos
diciendo es bueno me voy tomando
puntitos en el círculo unitario que se
esté morado que está ya visto en tres
dimensiones y lo que vamos a ir subiendo
con la función zeta a nuestra curva
rojita ok eso es esencialmente lo que
estamos diciendo con esta
parametrización entonces nuestro vector
digamos
nuestra curva está dado en términos de
una función vectorial que es r de teta
vamos a llamarle r de teta que
simplemente es coseno de teta en la
primera coordenada más seno de teta en
la segunda coordenada y vamos a sumar
también dos menos seno de teta en la 3ª
coordenada ok aquí ya tenemos
parametrizar nuestra curva y entonces
para calcular esta integral necesitamos
calcular quién es de r también y
entonces sabemos que de r simplemente es
la derivada de r respecto al parámetro
theta por de de beteta verdad por de
teta y esto simplemente después vamos
derivando
entrada por entrada la derivada de
coseno de teta es menos seno de teta en
la 1ª coordenada y ahora la derivada de
seno de teta es coseno de teta entonces
hay que tener coseno de teta en la
segunda coordenada y ahora la la
derivada de dos menos seno de teta es
pues la derivada de dos es una constante
simplemente cero y la derivada de menos
seno de teta es menos coseno dt está en
nuestra tercera coordenada y todo esto
multiplicado de teta que son nuestros
cambios infinitesimalmente pequeños en
la variable teta ya con esto podemos ir
calculando nuestra integral porque
tenemos que
efe punto de r aunque íbamos a calcular
primero el campo vectorial punto de r de
r simplemente es pues bueno vamos a ver
tenemos efe que en la primera coordenada
es menos ye cuadrada y si multiplica a
de r en la primera coordenada tenemos
menos en dónde está entonces menos por
menos es más y simplemente me queda que
cuadrada que multiplica a seno de teta
seno de teta vamos a ver ahora
multiplicamos la segunda en la segunda
centrada si tenemos equis que vamos a
sumar equis que multiplica a la segunda
coordenada de r que es coseno de teta
cocino de teta vámonos con las terceras
coordenadas tenemos esta cuadrada que
multiplica menos coseno detecta entonces
tendremos menos zeta cuadrada que
multiplica a jose no detecta y todo esto
multiplica de teta entonces si nosotros
queremos calcular la integral
simplemente vamos a calcular esta
integral a lo largo de nuestra curva se
y aquí ya está en términos del parámetro
entonces simplemente quema la integral
dibuje simplemente es la integral donde
se mueve el parámetro que es entre 0 y 2
y entonces vamos a bueno aquí el detalle
es que x y z pues ésta no están dados
aún en términos del parámetro theta
vamos a vamos a hacer esto que es lo
único que faltaba
entonces esto será igual a la
integración déjenme déjenme lo hago
mejor abajo para que se vea más claro
entonces esto será igual a la integral
de 0 a 2 pi de ye cuadrada pero cuadrada
es el seno cuadrado seno cuadrado de
teta verdad aquí está ya al cuadrado
será seno de teta al cuadrado que
multiplica a seno de teta por lo tanto
déjenme ponerlo esto en azul
esto nos quedará encuadrado por cero
pues simplemente es seno al cubo de ted
eso es de la la de multiplicar y
cuadrada por 9 teta ahora bien vamos a
multiplicar x que en este caso es coseno
de teta por jose no detecta también
verdad entonces de esta segunda de estas
de este segundo sumando tendremos que
sumar coseno cuadrado de t ahora lo más
complicado viene ahorita que es
multiplicar menos zeta cuadrada
coseno etc entonces vamos a subir
tantito para que se vea un poquito más
claro entonces quienes se está cuadrada
se está cuadrada es
2 - seno de teta al cuadrado déjenme
hacerlo un poquito más grande para que
sea más claro
se está cuadrada simplemente es
2 - seno de teta al cuadrado pero eso es
un binomio al cuadrado entonces tenemos
el primero al cuadrado que es cuatro
menos dos veces el primero por el
segundo que será cuatro por seno de teta
más el segundo al cuadrado que es seno
cuadrado de teta ahora bien nosotros
tenemos menos se está cuadrada entonces
menos se está cuadrada será menos cuatro
más cuatro seno de teta menos seno
cuadrado de teta ok
y esta es la expresión para menos se
está cuadrada ahora para calcular esta
integral todavía nos falta multiplicar
por cosa por por coseno de teta correcto
entonces vamos ya ya esté cerrando todo
esto porque menos está cuadrada al
multiplicarlo por coseno de teta nos
queda
déjenme ponerlo en -4 y multiplicar por
coseno de teta este es el primero luego
más 4 seno de teta y multiplicar otra
vez por coseno de teta también nos falta
menos seno cuadrado de teta y
multiplicar por este coseno dt está ok
entonces ya que tenemos todo esto hay
que multiplicarlo por de teta y ya
tenemos expresada la integral que
tenemos que resolver ya hemos planteado
no esté integral final y de hecho es una
integral definida en una dimensión que
es un poquito complicada de resolver se
ve muy grande así que vamos a tener que
sacar del baúl algunas identidades
trigonométricas para para poder resolver
esta esta integral propiamente pero
bueno el punto es que podremos hacerlo
ahí ahí voy a dejar este vídeo en el
próximo vídeo voy a calcular esta última
integral